what's happening baby
this week on thug notes we straight
clown and waited by Stephen King that
movie scared us pata me
first thing you better recognize is this
big-ass book always jumping across two
time periods but since telling it like
that will be a [ __ ] I'm gonna lay it on
y'all chronological the here is 1957 and
it's raining balls in the town of Derry
man well little shorty George playing
with a paper boat made by his older
brother Bill it's all good so that boat
floated to the storm drain where the
hell is the cloud doing down there man I
got some weird crackheads and dairy
anyway George tried to smash that boat
back but the clown spray rips his arm
off whoa he did three months go blind a
boy named Ben rolling back to the crib
when hold up that's that same red-nosed
hater the clown asks if you want to grab
a balloon and chill and Ben's tempted
but he said nah blood I'm straight and
the clown turns into a damn mummy
and Ben like mm-hmm and books later been
trying to duck a thug named Henry Bowers
and his crew of gangbangers by laying
low in the Barrens where he become tight
with two homies who also getting their
asses whooped by Henry George's older
bro Bill and his cat Eddie next day Ben
bill and Eddie got on rigging a dam with
some other young bloods named Richie and
Stan dropped by turns out most of them
be seeing-eye clown on the rag so as a
girl named Beverly and a brother named
Mike together all these cats make up the
losers Club and Richie thinking his
clown gotta be the one ghosting all
these little kids and dairy eventually
they recognized the clown shacked up in
the sewers and changed shape using some
speak all glamour apparently the only
way to end that fool is by busting a mad
lyrical flow of jokes and riddles while
buying on the edge the tongue oh it's
called the ritual of chewed and yeah man
it sounds pretty freaky but I like it
my shoulder loses his daddy's collection
of old ass photos and what do you know
that clown all up in those crusty stills
man this dude older than oh damn the
clown trying to bust out of the photo
will be all like break yourself fool
coming for you oh I don't like this
clown man so the losers do the logical
thing and get so high and trip balls
imagining it crash on earth millions of
years ago later it gets even wider when
he shaped shifts into the moon and star
conversating with Henry Bowers
he slides him a blade and say sprout
your dad in that girl Beverly got to go
so shank Papa Bowers get tugging out
Hilary get the jump on bed and while she
struggling to hoods just watch it go
down we're not even doing nothing but
Bev don't play man
oh yeah she kicks him right in the nuts
and bails that go hook up with the
losers Ville starts getting crunk about
how all the dogs don't give a [ __ ] about
what's happening to the kids and dairy
so they decide they gotta be the ones to
pull up on that beast
so they crew up and head down to the
sewers thing is Harry and his posse
creeping up from behind but it ain't
long before it goes both to Harry's boys
here he gets lost for hours I have to
reckon it with an inhaler and some
choice words the losers roll up on its
lair and bill gets his ass lost is some
kind of a void and if you think this Jam
was trippy before peep this spit out a
giant turtle who created the universe
say yo if you really want to kill it you
best start laying down that tube so bill
stop flowing bite down on the monster's
tongue and it scurry away like a little
old [ __ ] little old clown [ __ ]
after that the losers can't find their
way out of the tunnels but Beverly got
an idea hey boys drop your drawers and
wait what these kids are only 11 Stephen
man so having a sibling line at a freak
nasty poof the losers find their way out
of the sewers they all swear that if the
creature ain't dead they gotta come back
and put it in the ground no matter what
and that's for Henry that fool gets
tossed in the loony bin and takes the
fall for all of its murder
27 years later children start
disappearing and dairy again and might
get in specious so we ha let his old
crews say get your asses over here
Bloods it is back so all the losers
hustle back to Derry except Stan who get
so weird owie slits his damn wrists
meanwhile here we get a visit from it
who tell him it's time to bust out of
the big house to get revenge on those
losers the clown being a real dick
making the losers relive all kinds of
nasty mess from their childhood and if
that ain't enough Babs [ __ ] huh being
Bill's wife come to town unannounced
later Henry Bowers shanks mics at the
library but he's still kicking with the
little help from it Henry head over to
the hotel the ghost the losers buy a
beekeeping clutch and marks henry the
way most gangsters do it with a bottle
of Perrier Oh classic I begin word that
my guy wrecked and hit my control beb's
husband it's matched bills woman the
losers are all like nothing around man
time to end this fool I have to see him
Oh crazy
the losers drop in at its digs bill
Ritchie and addy start laying down the
ritual of tude hand up into that void
and it chops Eddy's damn arm off he did
when the monsters start crawling away
then bless every one of its eggs and
bill crushes its heart like a geez
now that it's finally dead they grab
Bill's wife and chunk deuces out of the
tunnel no gang bang required this time
all the losers go their separate ways
and slowly start to forget what the hell
just happened
Bill's wife all whacked out in the head
from all the crazy she saw but after
bill gives her a ride on his hoopty ass
childhood bike she snaps right out of it
but still don't remember what went down
you might be thinking why would a gnarly
beast like it set up shop in a hood like
Gary well this spot ain't the innocent
small town it seemed like all that leave
of the beaver Bulls got a dark side
brewing under it people who are crooked
violent races is [ __ ] and don't give a
damn about what's happening to these
little kids see it acting like a mirror
of the crooked ass people and dairy just
peep this quote of homies jabbering
about the monster the one glimpse I
caught of him it looked like he had a
Winchester bolt action and it wasn't
until later that I figured out I must
have thought of that because that's what
I had Biff Marlow thought he had a
remington because that was what he had
and when I asked Jimmy about it he said
I got was shooting an old Springfield
just like his hmm funny huh hey brother
remember the monster packing the same
piece they were packin weapon that
decline is a reflection of all the raw
violence inside the heart of autumn hood
rats matter of fact ain't no mistake
that it roll around decked out like a
clown cuz just like a clown
the people of Derry seemed nice to the
kids on the outside but on the inside
it's all bull that clown wouldn't even
exist if it weren't for dairies dog
deeds
see it's only able to hit the scene when
a horrible event go down like child
abuse or murder it's like a gnarly cycle
where the messed up things the dairy
folk do inspires it to terrorize the
people which then encourages the people
to do even more whack spit and cuz this
cycle just keeps going and going it's
been chilling and dairy for a long-ass
time it's become a part of dairy
something as much a part of the town as
the stand pipe or the canal Abasi Park
or the library only it's not a matter of
our geography somehow it's gotten inside
this whole cycle Jam go even deeper cuz
there be circular imagery all up in this
huge as book the kids circle back to the
hood roots when they return to Derry as
adults to live whoop on the monster
family replaced her abusive daddy
with an abusive husband the only way
they're able to beat it in the end
it's my throwing back to the mental
states of their childhood and flexing
their imagination they even recognize
that past events happening all over
again
like when big boy Ben peeps some BZ
reading the same story she read to him
back in a day and my suppose believe
that's just coincidence because I don't
it's something really staple in the past
and present together here or am i only
imagining it
the losers always form a circle at
important points like when they promise
to wreck it if he dare shows his face
and dairy again when the dose tried to
remember what went down back then and
even when everybody gathers around at at
Beverly's that ah nevermind man I can't
say that she's only like eleven maybe
all this cycle jive just preaching the
great a point about evil just like it
evil been around since the beginning of
time but it's only when humans arrived
that it started to take shape that says
humans keep doing dark deeds over and
over again and been thriving for
centuries so maybe that's Kings message
evil only becomes for real when humans
allow it to take control of us and guide
all of our nasty qualities like greed
jealousy and violence it's always been
here since the beginning the time since
before there were men anywhere it was
here then sleeping maybe waiting for the
ice to melt waiting for the people to
come yo thanks for chilling with me and
my library today y'all and yo one more
thing before you go cuz we've got big
news this year we've launched an audio
series thug notes get lit in each
episode I dive it's a list of the
trillest writers characters plots themes
and more all from the world of
literature so if you like what your boy
doc sweet does here on thug notes check
out thug notes get lit it's available on
iTunes and all these spots you find
podcasts and as always we've got lots
more videos on the way so
click here to go to our channel page and
if you haven't already make sure to
subscribe while you're there catch y'all
next time players peace
[Music]